nos dicen que un almacén de electrónica
envía televisiones y reproductores dvd
de manera combinada a distribuidores de
todo el país el peso de tres
televisiones y cinco reproductores dvd
es 62.5 libras y el peso de tres
televisiones y dos reproductores dvd es
52 libras nos están dando dos
combinaciones construye un sistema de
ecuaciones que representa esta situación
entonces resuelve lo para encontrar
cuánto pesan cada televisión y
reproductor dvd aquí nos están dando dos
pedazos de información los cuales
podemos transformar en ecuaciones el
primero es que el peso de tres
televisiones y cinco reproductores dvd
es 62.5 libras también nos dicen que el
peso de tres televisiones y dos
reproductores dvd es 52 libras podemos
transformar esto directamente en
ecuaciones si hacemos t el peso de una
televisión y de el peso de un
reproductor dvd este enunciado de aquí
establece que tres veces el número de
televisiones o más bien 3
por el peso de las televisiones más
cinco veces el peso de los reproductores
dvd es igual a 60 y 2.5 libras eso es
exactamente lo que dice este primer
enunciado el segundo anunciado el peso
de tres televisiones y dos reproductores
dvd lo podemos escribir como tres
televisiones más dos reproductores dvd
el peso de tres televisiones más el peso
de dos reproductores dvd es igual a 52
libras bien ya tenemos un sistema de
ecuaciones ya cumplimos con la primera
parte elabora un sistema de ecuaciones
ahora tenemos que resolverlo al ver
nuestro sistema de ecuaciones y que
tenemos dos términos iguales tenemos
tres de aquí y tres de acá podemos
entonces multiplicar una de estas
ecuaciones por un factor adecuado de tal
manera que cuando sumemos esta ecuación
con la ecuación que tenemos arriba los
términos ente se van a cancelar eso es
lo que vamos a hacer y podemos hacer
esto de sumar ecuaciones pues como vimos
cuando revisamos los fundamentos de
álgebra cuando tú haces algo de un lado
de la ecuación lo tienes que hacer del
otro
la ecuación si sumas 3 de un lado tienes
que sumar 3 del otro lado así es que se
agregó esto al lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación se agregó esto en azul al lado
izquierdo de la ecuación en rojo puedo
sumar 52 al lado derecho pues esto es lo
mismo el lado izquierdo es igual a 52 es
decir estamos sumando 52 también al lado
izquierdo solo que escrito de otra
manera ahora antes de hacer esa suma lo
que tengo que hacer es multiplicar esta
segunda ecuación por menos 1 así es que
al multiplicar por menos uno tenemos
menos tres t más menos dos de igual a
menos 52 no he cambiado la información
de la ecuación sólo le x menos 1 he
hecho eso pues ahora que sume las
ecuaciones estos términos 3 t se van a
cancelar hagamos eso sumamos estas
ecuaciones y recuerda lo único que
estamos haciendo es sumar lo mismo a
ambos lados de la ecuación estamos
sumando ambos lados menos 52 ahora que
hemos multiplicado la segunda ecuación
por menos uno pues menos tres más menos
12 es exactamente igual a menos 52
hagamos la suma entonces 3
- 3 t se cancelan para eso estamos
haciendo esto ahora 5 de más menos 2 de
5 de menos 2 de es igual a 3 de y del
lado derecho nos queda 62.5 menos 52 o
62.5 menos 52 esto es igual a 10.5 10.5
ahora dividiendo entre 3 ambos lados de
la ecuación que nos queda del lado
izquierdo nos queda de y del lado
derecho nos queda 10.53 calculemos lo
vamos a dividir entre 3 10.5 10 entre 13
es igual a 33 por 39 los estamos 10
menos 91 bajamos el 5 por supuesto
tenemos el punto decimal y 15 entre 3
nos da 55 por 315 los restamos 15 menos
15 es igual a 0 así es que esto nos
resulta que de el peso de cada
reproductor dvd es de 3.5 libras vamos
ahora a sustituir este valor de d en una
de las ecuaciones que tenemos arriba
para encontrar el peso de cada
televisión usemos
ecuación de arriba tenemos que tres por
t 5 por el valor de 3.5 el valor desde
que acabamos de encontrar 5 por 3.5
recuerda
estamos buscando valores que cumplan con
ambas ecuaciones así es que esto va a
ser igual a 62.5 que tenemos ahora 3 t
más 5 por 3.5 5 por 3 es 15 5.5 es 2.5
15 más 2.5 esto es 17.5 y esto es igual
a 60 y 2.5
vamos ahora a restar 17.5 a ambos lados
de la ecuación
estamos 17.5 ambos lados de la ecuación
lo cual nos queda 3 t del lado izquierdo
estos términos se cancelan queríamos
dejar a 3 t sola del lado izquierdo por
lo que 3 te va a ser igual a veamos 62.5
17.5 tan sólo queda 62 17 veamos 62
menos 7 es igual a 55 si restamos otros
nos queda 45 así es que esto va a ser
igual a 45 dividiendo ahora entre 3
ambos lados de la ecuación nos resulta
que t es igual a 15 hemos resuelto
nuestro sistema encontramos que el peso
del reproductor dvd es 3.5 libras
mientras que el peso de la televisión es
de 15 libras hemos concluido